so you said that we can throw anything
at you bring it on okay here we go so
this is Jo who goes by at Jo underscore
k Jo is that somebody's name
that's that looks like somebody's name
jo yes foreign and at a Deborah Harry
reference um here's the deal I love your
radio show listen to you on podcast
really funny interesting Neil can you
talk about the physics behind the
Bermuda Triangle mu to triangle uh no
I'm not authorized to divulge aha
there are actual physics Jo it's just
that if Neil tells you he has to Killian
yeah yeah so for the longest while in
fact it become nated in the publication
of a book in the 1970s called the
Bermuda Triangle there a couple of
movies one a TV movie okay I think there
might have even been a first-run movie
that explore the mysteries of the
Bermuda Triangle where ships would
disappear right and no one would know
where they went they wouldn't show up
where they were headed aircraft aircraft
would disappear and it was argued that
there might have been some kind of warp
in the space-time continuum of course
you got it give it the most extreme
example not that the ships sank or that
the plane crash yeah but you ever
noticed Chuck there's never any missing
trains trains never disappear how funny
is that right exactly so it turns out if
you looked at the total amount of
Commerce that moved through the Bermuda
Triangle and it's a region that connects
Bermuda Florida and I forgot some other
island down down there in the Caribbean
okay that if you look at the total flux
of traffic air traffic and shipping
traffic through there
and you look at the rate at which you
would lose a ship or a plane would crash
in the world right it was not any
different from any other place in the
world except that there's more traffic
and so there's more ships ah that's also
if you do the statistics right it comes
out there it comes out to that way maybe
right right so so the answer to yeah yo
is how does it happen all you mark
there is no
serious physics going on in the Bermuda
Triangle so basically what we need to do
is check the bottom of the sea drain the
Atlantic do a really cool totally so it
would totally reveal all your missing
ships and and like I said the day you'd
start missing trains and then we can
have demographic conversation yeah there
you go